jetzt ist einfach mal der ganze schrank
der die ganzen verpackten sachen liegen
da unten die muss jetzt wieder
reinräumen hey das geht ab und kommen
bei einem neuen video
und ja ich habe ja schon war dinge wie
die jungs beziehungsweise mädchen machen
teil eins gemacht um heute gibt es den
zweiten teil also ihr müsst euch das so
vorstellen mädchen und jungen fällt
sicher in mega vielen situationen ein
bisschen anders bzw ein bisschen lustig
anders ich habe mir so 34 sachen mal
wieder rausgesucht schaut so einfach an
welcher gefällt mir daumen hoch und was
hier auf jeden fall noch loswerden muss
bitte seht jetzt nicht zu persönlich
oder so ist alles nur spaß von mir also
nichts wirklich ernst gemeint schon ein
bisschen so aber viel spaß verbreiten so
nicht will man sagen japan
logischerweise mit punkt eins an und
zwar kennt ihr das war bestimmt er steht
als junge oder mädchen von den schrank
wie es scheint morgens vor der schule
oder extremer ist natürlich immer noch
wenn man abends rausgeht irgendwas macht
oder so und dann überlegt wir so was
ziehe ich denn heute mal an und bei jung
sieht das dann so aus
was ziehen wir dann weiter an
die rose das teil und fast schon ist bei
mir zumindest so also ich achte jetzt
nicht unbedingt darauf was ich so
anziehe weil ehrlich gesagt sich immer
gerne spaß weil es interessiert mich
schon ein bisschen aber ich habe immer
schnell sachen gefunden
und ja mädchen bei denen sieht so aus
ich treffe halt endlich den robert wir
was gefällt die man wohl
sieht scheiße aus ich habe echt blöde
klamotten drehen das passt gar nicht
dazu mensch das sowieso nicht nee
nein man das sieht doch ne scheiße aus
ich habe es bis jetzt wirklich nur so
mitbekommen wenn es anders ist dann
schreibt das einfach mal in die
kommentare
aber ich glaube mir nicht ab auf
facebook noch gefragt haben ganz wieder
dieses beispiel genannt und ich denke
mal damit habe ich schon so ein bisschen
recht kommen auch schon zu punkt 2
und zwar kann ich das immer nur so
anhand der resultate festmachen sag ich
mal ich bin auf facebook unterwegs auf
instagram scheißegal
und dann siehst du mal ein bild von dem
jungen zwischen den ganzen bildern von
den mädchen da gab es ein profil
aktualisiert das oder was weiß ich gegen
ein foto hochgeladen hat und so ist er
heute ein foto
so ich denke jetzt ist mal wieder an der
zeit mein profil weg zu aktualisieren
das hier oder so was für
bildunterschrift nein nicht einfach
hochladen und fertig soll scheißegal
der ein oder andere junge schreibt
vielleicht auch in drei wörter darunter
wenn er jetzt gerade freundin hat oder
ihnen das und das ja keine ahnung auf
jeden fall die meisten schreiben aber
einfach gar nichts so laden einfach die
foto hoch so und wenn ich dann mal die
fotos von den mädchen ein bisschen
genauer unter die lupe nehme sagt man da
jetzt dass du selbst vom mädchen von
denen man es gar nicht erwartet da steht
plötzlich sammler ticks drin da fragt
man sich
seit wann bist du so poetisch begabt
oder so da war für diesen scheiß text
her
die schönsten zitate für mein neues
facebook profilbild 828 für mein neues
pbc so das gesamtbild stimmt schon mal
jetzt brauchen wir noch einen schönen
spruch nehme einfach den wenn man zwei
stunden mit dem seminar zusammen sitzt
kommt es einem vor als wäre es eine
minute sitzt man allerdings eine minute
auf einem
heißen ofen meinte man es wären zwei
stunden
das ist relativ ich weiß jetzt zwar
nicht ganz was das bedeuten soll aber
wenn er gibt es bestimmt und es hört
sich auch schön an so posten wenn man
sich das so vorstellt dass ein mädchen
oder manche jungen sind auch so aber
echt nur ganz ganz wenige
die sitzt da und tippen dann fünf
minuten diesen text ein oder wie ja und
zum schlüssel was man noch ganz viele
geschrieben haben ich habe hier so eine
xbox drin geht es ums zocken will
vielleicht zwölf einmal erläutert
projektleiter und bei mädchen dann
natürlich gibt es auch die ein oder
andere ausnahme aber die meisten mit dem
man versucht zu zocken wirklich versucht
die situation überhaupt an mir was habe
ich jetzt gemacht scheiße ich glaub
jetzt habe ich den controller muss ich
auch noch an machen
warum das denn jetzt ich hab noch nicht
mal in münchen
warum macht ihr denn jetzt so komischen
dreieck dörfern kann er nicht jetzt
einfach mal über die mauer den blöcken a
a
jetzt bin ich doch schon wieder tot ja
leute ich hoffe ihr habt so ein bisschen
mit humor genommen also ich sehe jetzt
zum zweit war ich meine das nicht so war
wie es vielleicht tun backen quatsch das
habt ihr bestimmt verstanden ja
ansonsten wenn ihr mir dennoch recht
gibt dann hast du einfach mal daumen
nach oben da hier in der beschreibung
instagram nicht vergessen wenn ihr nicht
verpassen sollte hier auf der linken
seite geht es weiter mit einem netz
video ist das nomis war das und hier auf
der anderen seite mit der ersten folge
von dinge wie die jungs bzw mädchen
wandeln ich bin dann raus wir sehen uns
am mittwoch da kommt ein fan wurde video